power is a word that americans are just
very uncomfortable with i must say that
we know it we know that there's the
other side of the tracks and there's the
people that live in the nice houses we
have all of these euphemisms that we use
for
power structures and for social classes
i think there very definitely is an
upper class in the united states and
indeed that's been the starting point
of my research
if a group is a dominant group or a
ruling group we would expect them to
have more of what people value in a
society and certainly this
upper social class we've been talking
about has more wealth it has more income
it certainly has access to the best best
education and health care and so on so
on all the measures of who benefits
i think there's that shows that they are
a ruling class there is what i call a
corporate community
which means that the large corporations
in america are interconnected through
ownership
through sharing of information through
putting out products together
through having the same directors
through
hiring each other's managers
that it truly is in that sense a
community
this is where we get back to this
question about is there a power
structure
americans are used to thinking well if
there's a power structure we wouldn't
even be allowed to be in politics but in
america you're allowed to run for
president you can run for anything you
want there's just one thing you better
have several million dollars or access
to people that that have several million
dollar so you see we can say in the one
hell it's very fair anybody can run
but in fact not anybody can when you get
down to the specifics of the matter so
we have a formally
open
and liberal system but in practice the
way things work out is that the rich get
richer
and they are able to
continue a set of policies that that
maximize their advantages
we're going to find out who rules
america with the country's foremost
expert
right now on alternative views
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if there's one subject that you will not
see on the traditional media
particularly television it's something
about the american power structure
who has power who benefits from this who
controls things influences things
well we have the man with us tonight who
knows more about power than anybody else
in the country you may know him by the
name of g william domhoff from a lot of
his books
the first book which he came out with as
far as i know was sea wright mills and
the power elite c wright wil mills was
the first one to come up with a
comprehensive look at power in the
united states in 1956
and then
bill's first
big book comprehensive book was who
rules america which has been read by
many many people and others such as the
bohemian grove the higher circles the
powers that be
and the most recent one who rules
america now
if you want to find out
just who does real america and it ain't
you and i
well you really want to read that book
i want to we'll ask you his first
question by using a quote
from
c wright mills in his book power elite
or some other book he said if you
if somebody starts talking about power
and the use of power you're
automatically a muckraker
right
power is a word that americans are just
very uncomfortable with we're willing to
talk about influence and what we
basically like to believe is that
individuals and groups can join together
to influence specific issues but power
is something that happens in europe it's
it's part of the whole american
experience to
put no emphasis upon the idea of social
class and to put no emphasis
on the idea of power
why do you think this is
i think that it comes out of out of the
classic liberal tradition and out of
american history of rebelling against
the
the king and in the american revolution
but
and then from there i think it's because
the american experience
has been seemingly very individualistic
that is people have moved across the
country there are is evidence of upward
mobility people have become wealthy they
have been able to get education and
change their station and life a little
bit
and i think that then reinforces this
kind of
belief so that the idea that there is a
power structure and a social structure
is then something that
that we want we want to ignore now i
must say that we know it we know that
there's the other side of the tracks and
there's the people that live in the nice
houses we have all of these euphemisms
that we use
for
power structures and for social classes
what is the dominant view in the
universities in the united states of
what you call the power structure i
think the dominant view
in
in the university
something we call pluralism which says
that
influence the united states is exercised
by
specific individuals who come together
as a coalition or an interest group to
work on one particular kind of issue so
we always stay at the level of
individuals and groups and we never talk
in terms of long-standing institutional
structures which sounds pretty abstract
but that gets down to things like
corporations or foundations that for 60
or 80 years have been giving out great
amount of money to to influence
directions that uh policy take i think
that whole that whole kind of level
drops out of our thinking and i think
that our educational system does
reinforce that and what led you to take
this different approach to power why did
you become dissatisfied with the
pluralist approach and start looking at
the power structure in different terms i
think that for me it was probably
because of many of the events of the
1960s
when people
tried to
exercise their rights such as in the
civil rights movement
or such as in the
anti-war movement of the time or even in
some of the attempts by consumer
advocates such as ralph nader
basically when when they seem to be
meeting a stone wall
then you kind of uh
think there may be something else more
there i like what ralph nader said in
regard to
in regard to your question that he said
is that if you want to find out about
the power structure you've got to go out
there and kind of
bump up against it
the way you find it's there is when you
hit these brick walls
and
as i saw that happening i got more
interested in
trying to see if there was this class
and institutional structure
and basically i started out in a i think
a good old american way by trying to
trace
individuals in their in their
in their activities and what i found
standing behind these individuals i
believe are large corporations large
foundations a series of research
institutes a series of policy discussion
groups that make it so that a david
rockefeller
is not merely an individual but is in
fact constantly
involved whether it's with a bank or his
foundation or policy discussion group
like the council on foreign relations
and then one begins to see
that there's an ongoing
institutional structure and so that even
then when david rockefeller retires you
see that the people that now run chase
manhattan bank that now are the
directors of the council on foreign
relations continue to be the people
that run
the country
so that
when you get a little time perspective
on it you start to see the individuals
change a little bit but that they come
from the same social background and they
come from the same
large
institutions so i tried then to find
that
structure that stood behind our
individual actions well let's take a
look at this and i guess we should start
with the class the class structure and
class nature of the united states now we
hear about middle class very frequently
it's written a lot of things are studied
about the middle class and a lot of
things been written about the middle
class you see frequently lower middle
class and lower but you don't see too
much written about upper class now if
there's a middle class there has to be
an upper right
i think there very definitely is an
upper class in the united states and
indeed that's been the starting point
of my research
is to start
with
social clubs exclusive private schools
summer resorts to start with what
we can see if we will but look
to see these people as a set of
interacting and intermarrying
set of families who have developed a
whole set of social institutions that
preserve
their way of life once we have located
these various schools clubs resorts
retreats debutant balls
then we can understand
the historical continuity of
social upper class in america it's my
belief
that about half a percent of americans
are part of what i would call a social
upper class
and these people uh own about 20 to 25
percent of all the privately held wealth
in the united states that is if we took
all of your wealth which might be your
car your house your insurance policy if
we threw in your guitar and everything
we took all of that wealth plus the
stocks and bonds and real estate in
america we put all that in a big pile
20 to 25 percent of all of that one half
of one percent of the people have that
in the united states and what my thesis
basically says is that those people that
have that
20 to 25 percent of all the privately
held wealth are not mere individuals
that are scattered here and there and
are kind of rare and don't know each
other but in fact they
are are closely knit they know each
other they see the world the same way
they do discuss with each other the
kinds of policies that they think
would further their way of life so in
that sense we then talk about them
in this more sociological abstract sense
that
they're not just families because in
fact there are these ongoing
institutional kinds of structures and
they are
uh structures that do matter and they
make a difference to a lot of americans
as they attempt to emulate these people
as they attempt to become part of these
institutions and so on now under
this their institutions and their
structures do
two things or three they first they
perpetuate themselves
they exclude other people they have
mechanisms to exclude other people from
joining them
absolutely and but they also they use
the mechanisms to bring up new blood
when they think these people have their
right credentials and right
i think one of the most dramatic
examples that i know of that frank
concerns the way in which
moderate
members of the upper class responded to
the
civil rights movement of the 60s and the
rebellions that were going on in the
inner cities in the ghettos at that time
and that was that a number of these
institutions of which were talking
decided that
they really had to
find the best and the brightest of the
black community and to educate them so
they could be
more a part of the of the corporate
structure and what they simply did
was to get money from the ford and
rockefeller foundations and a couple
others and then to go to leading private
schools and say we want to create a
scholarship program for black students
this program is called abc a better
chance and literally over the space than
of 10 or 15 years
many thousands of young black students
were taken into these prep schools and
then from there went on to major
colleges and universities with
fellowships and these people are now out
there in their 30s
being in the media being in corporate
law working for
corporations
we've interviewed some of these people
it's very fascinating the way it shows
you so nicely about class because these
people gradually take on the style and
manner of the school of which they were
apart and they they tell us it's very
funny that they'll go home and people
say you're starting to talk different
you're and and they say you know it's i
go and i'd like to visit my family but
my other friends i don't have anything
in common with them anymore and that's
what we mean you see by then a social
class
if one has read all about american
history and knows about various kinds of
arts that most people don't know about
if you've had european vacations
then you want to talk to other people
that can talk your language
and and gradually then these people come
to feel different
from the very
group that they originally came from i
use this example because i think it is
so dramatic in the sense that we're
taking very poor people
out of out of the ghetto
and taking them to this private school
where they're one of two or three or
four black people at what age by the way
oh 14 15 16
and
and making them
part of this class in the sense of
putting them there and then and then
they gradually just out of human
processes of while you're at school you
certainly want to relate to other people
you want to get along and before you
know it you're like the people that uh
that you're going to school with
socialization i mean that's right
these people
intermarrying with their white social
social upper class people or do they
bring black women into this program as
well there are black women in the
program as well
and i don't know the answer to that
question in terms of any systematic data
yet we've only interviewed a few
of the people but definitely then there
is
some intermarriage i guess the next big
question then
there is this upper class in the united
states
is it a ruling class a governing class
and is it cohesive yeah i
i believe that
first it is cohesive and and secondly
that
it is a ruling class
i think that we see the cohesion
in the fact that
these people are members of each other's
clubs so to speak that is if we look at
club memberships all over the united
states we would find that
a leading banker in new york may well be
in clubs in los angeles and and san
francisco
we find in the case of a club i've
studied with
some care called the bohemian club in
san francisco that people from all of
the united states come to its two-week
retreat in the last
part of july and
sleep together in tents and huts and
teepees and just kind of go to summer
camp together they literally do go to
summer camp
together there's a lot of that kind of
social cohesiveness there's also
cohesiveness in the corporate world in
that they sit on each other's corporate
boards
so that the head of chase manhattan bank
such as david rockefeller until recent
years will sit on two or three other
corporation boards but the head of those
corporations will also sit on the board
of chase manhattan bank so they take in
each other's laundry at the economic
level as well they also come together to
talk about more general issues whether
it's foreign policy or kinds of domestic
policy at what i call discussion groups
but this means organizations like the
committee for economic development the
council on foreign relations the
conference board the business council
there's numerous of these groups so i
think there is
cohesiveness
in this group as a social class and as
and in terms of its economic interest
we've been
talking a lot or referring to the
council on foreign relations committee
for economic development trilateral
commission
let's talk in greater detail about the
policy planning mechanisms some of these
organizations that we've been talking
about because i think this is probably
the thing that people know least about
you don't find them in history books and
you don't find them in economics
textbooks and all tell us about these
basically these were
these organizations
were all created
at different times in the 20th century
in the face of particular problems that
were faced
by the corporate community in the case
of the council on foreign relations
it was formed shortly after world war
one
when uh
states people came and corporate leaders
came back from their side and they said
we have to have a better perspective
on foreign relations now that we're
clearly going to be the dominant power
in the world
and they created this discussion group
in order to make themselves more
sophisticated about these issues
these these organizations are funded by
large corporations and buy
foundations
they then bring together these business
people for discussions with academic
experts these academic experts are
basically housed at institutes on
major campuses the harvard yale
princeton columbia stanford johns
hopkins berkeley mit caltech nexus
and these experts are also housed at
think tanks like the rand corporation
and various institutes for strategic
thinking here there and everywhere so
what we have at a policy discussion
group is the bringing together
a variety of
academic opinions
with
this range of corporate leaders
and they then discuss a particular issue
as i say a foreign policy issue a
monetary policy issue a particular
domestic issue and they try to work out
ideas that make sense to all of them
now from the corporate point of view
by listening say they got a liberal
academic and a more conservative
academic in the same room and they
listen to you guys argue
and then they see what makes sense in
terms of their
view of the world and entertainment
right so i might then so then in that
situation
now beyond then becoming sophisticated
about policies they also you see are
looking at each other
in terms of who can
do this more general kind of task
meaning this and i think we've all seen
it in our lives we have friends that
might be very good at their particular
job they might be very good say it at
running a business but if you ask them
to do a more general thing like be on
the city council
they maybe don't do very well because
they don't relate well to other groups
we see this with faculty people people
do a fine job in their department but
maybe they would you wouldn't want them
on a general committee of the faculty
because they they're impatient with
student demands
or they get angry with the
administration so we say we don't want
to put that person on that committee so
what they do is informally learn about
each other's leadership capabilities but
what i that's one thing that's learned
at these organizations but the other
thing it's learned is which academic
expert makes sense to me and can i
personally relate to
so it's at these organizations that you
meet somebody like a henry kissinger and
you say he not only makes sense but i
get along with him personally
so you develop then this this
relationship between the corporate
community and the expert community at
these organizations so they are a place
where these people get a more general
view where they get sophisticated where
they informally select each other as
leaders
where they inject academic opinion into
their
into their perspectives where they
look academic experts over to become
potential advisors in the government
and then and very importantly
what these organizations do is they
legitimate
these people
as fair-minded experts
you see the interesting thing about
politics in america in terms of policies
as opposed to electing individuals is
that the political organizations of the
ruling class
are not called political now this is
that's an irony yeah in a way that is
all the groups in america that are
called non-partisan bipartisan
non-political that's the political
organization
of the ruling class in america you see
if you go out and say i don't understand
how you can talk about a ruling class
there's a democrats over here there's
republicans over here that's politics
isn't it no that's just deciding which
individuals will fill offices politics
in the important sense of of which
policies we all agree are makes sense
that happens in non-political
organizations so when the committee for
economic development puts out a
statement it says committee for economic
development a non-partisan group of
business people today suggested we alter
the social security system in the
following way
and then they say look some of our
members are democrats some of our
members are republicans we're trying to
get something that's good for all of
america we're trying to transcend
politics we're trying to do something
that's that's in the national interest
now once you say yeah that's fair we've
got to get beyond this fight between
republicans and democrats they're
they're they're people that have they
can run an organization their success in
america and then we identify with them
because of their high status and because
they're part of this fair-minded
organization academic experts from
harvard have helped them and from yale
and who are we
you know
to argue with somebody from harvard and
yale plus a successful business leader
and that's what we call legitimation
in my mind of of their policies and we
respect them i know that because i when
i go around and talk about these things
or debate these things and so many times
people will stand up afterwards they'll
say hey who why shouldn't the man from
general motors run the country he's a
winner
he's shown like iacocca they're talking
about iacocca should be president right
look at him he's a wonderful guy he's
proven it he's run these corporations
what do you want for nothing others
that's
that has made him somebody that
americans will will accept and relate to
and and they'll go along with those
policies so that's the
role then to come back to these
organizations that they play this kind
of legitimation of policies that are in
the general interest of the ruling class
and are labeled
uh nonpartisan and then these policies
not only are put into effect
but also the people from these
organizations
are placed in positions of
decision-making power in the government
right and i think that the policies
incidentally to be a little academic
about it i think that the policies could
be
implemented without necessarily putting
the people in government
but it's the fact that the people that
go into gov go into government that's
what we can see most clearly and that's
what people can kind of
can kind of relate to or identify with
they can see what you're talking about
if you show the movement of donald regan
from merrill lynch to the business
roundtable to government and then if you
say the same thing happens under
democrats or if you show the movement of
henry kissinger from
harvard to the council on foreign
relations to the paid staff of nelson
rockefeller and then finally to the
government with under nixon
then we can see that the
what's happening
it might be that a lot of times that
important policies come out of these
organizations without necessarily the
particular person
coming to government
uh
where
to put this then at the level of persons
again from the point of view of these
academic experts what they're trying to
do
is to attach themselves to somebody that
they think
is going to
be successful because the culmination of
an academic expert's career is to be a
henry kissinger and when i say that i'm
thinking of brzezinski brzezinski was
always sort of in the shadow of
kissinger but he was always in these
discussion groups i'm talking about he
headed an important think tank at
columbia and he was always in council on
foreign relations study group
well
david rockefeller asked brzezinski to
head up the staff for this organization
called the trilateral commission which
is a discussion group
of
prominent leaders from the western
european nations plus japan plus the
united states incidentally they're all
people all these countries have a
council on foreign relations and they're
basically people from the national
council on foreign relations
david rockefeller asked brzezinski to
head this
the staff for this this uh new
discussion group that started in the 70s
and when the man from coca-cola
suggested to david rockefeller that
jimmy carter be a part of that group
brzezinski met carter at the council at
the trilateral commission now from
brzezinski's point of view
he looked and he said this guy
might make it to president
i'm going to bet on him in effect and
the result will be i get to be
a national security adviser someday so
there is that whole subjective part of
what the academic is doing there in
terms of this is a guy i can relate to
and i think he's going to be a winner
so we could i could explain all
of of what i've been talking about from
a subjective careerist point of view for
an individual like a kissinger or a
brzezinski but
my point is a lot of them have bet on
the wrong guy that is they decided they
were going to work for george romney who
remembers george romney or they decided
they were going to
work for some particular democrat that
lost out somewhere made a fatal faux pas
and so we don't hear of them but they
probably maybe had some important policy
inputs but they themselves did not
arrive in the government because they
bet on the wrong political horse so what
this these organizations do is to very
much limit
the range of policies that are even that
seem discussable that's right and what
is legitimated in the in the the minds
of the american people
and also in congress but there's a
parallel thing that goes on in public
opinion shaping too is there not i think
so and i think the important thing to
say is that is precisely what you just
did and that is it's not that these
people sort of just pour opinions into
our head
but rather that they try to manage the
limits of respectable opinion which are
fairly wide as those things go in the
world but nonetheless kinds of liberal
opinions and kinds of ultra-conservative
opinions get labeled in some way as
too utopian or too kooky or un-american
and too extreme or too erratic and we
can you know you know the
the way the ultra conservatives do it is
to call it anti you know to call it
communist or socialist or unamerican the
moderates say sounds awfully utopian to
me or it sounds awfully academic i mean
the appeal is to the practical if we can
legitimate something as practical and
american
then it's okay
but very definitely there's a constant
argument that goes on to try to keep
some opinions not respectable
and to see that
you have to look historically at some
particular argument and here i just say
quickly that the best example of that
involves
the famous economist john maynard keynes
and his views about the use of
government spending to to stabilize a
capitalist economy
there are many ways of being there are
many policies that follow from keynes
there are many different things you
could do and be a keynesian
but what happened in america from 1935
to 1965
was essentially an intellectual struggle
in which the business community was saw
that a very conservative keynesianism
would make sense to them
but that a more liberal keynesianism
they didn't want they didn't want to
accept and furthermore weren't forced to
accept because our working class is not
powerful enough organizationally to
force a liberal kind of keynesianism
such as happens in
sweden say
so
basically what was what kane said in the
middle thirties
slowly got whittled down you know just
the way you described got whittled down
and so we have a very conservative kind
of keynesianism and now right now
in america
we are seeing the amazing thing whether
intentionally or not we are seeing the
amazing and complete application of
keynesian economics to the american
economy by somebody who a totally
rejects keynes and claims he's a supply
cider and c doesn't understand economics
and this is ronald reagan but what has
happened is that we've just had a total
keynesian recovery in the united states
because the key thing in kane is you run
a deficit and you do government spending
now that's what ronald reagan has done
but it's all of course been military
spending and we call it a military
keynesianism
ronald reagan is behaving as a keynesian
even while saying he's not and he may
not know he's a keynesian i don't know
if he i know you never know
so there is there are a whole set of
mechanisms that legitimate some opinions
and make other opinions seem
far out or not worth studying
the mass media do this too my studies
the mass media i find that once this
policy has been set
that the media will follow up on this
and you will not find any discussion on
anything on the other side
of this preset agenda by these people
you're talking about or if it is
discussed it's highly criticized but
generally it's just ignored
in there one another aspect of
determining whether a ruling class is
also a governing class
uh or the upper class is also a ruling
class and that is you have to look at
where the decision makers come from to
see if the prime decision makers come
from this ruling class or the people
whom this ruling class is selected right
i think that that's another very useful
way of of understanding about power
because it's the most visible to us that
is we can watch people we may we right
now are not we don't know
what's being talked about and said
usually at the national security council
or in the
private meetings in the white house but
we sure do know who's there
and
to give you an example if we take the
secretary of treasury
as an important position and we look at
um a few of them for instance under
kennedy
who ran on a a
a platform of getting the country moving
again
we've got to get beyond this stodgy
republican establishment and so on and
yet when he was elected the person he
put in charge of treasury was a man
named c douglas dillon from a man worth
several hundreds of millions of dollars
who from a major investment
house in in new york
when we jumped to jimmy carter who was
our populist and
hamilton jordan
assured us that we were going to see new
faces
in fact the person that we got as our
secretary of treasury was a man named w
michael blumenthal who was the head of
bendix corporation a trustee of the
council on foreign relations a trustee
of the committee for economic
development a trustee of princeton
university
and a member of the trilateral
commission and he becomes our secretary
of treasury
now ronald reagan comes in and he's
going to get rid of the mess in
washington from a neo-conservative
perspective but our secretary of
treasury is a man named donald regan or
was and he was his first secretary of
treasury as you know and and donald
regan who was from merrill lynch he was
a member of the council on foreign
relations he was a trustee of the
committee for economic development he
was a trustee of the business roundtable
and what i'm saying of course with those
examples is that when we look at the
cabinet level appointments of the past
40 years at the least but we could go
back further but if we look at the last
40 years that whether it's a republican
or a democrat whether it's a populist or
a neo-conservative whatever particular
ticket they run on or ideology they run
on in order to attract a coalition of
voters
when they turn to the question of
governing when they turn to the question
of how are they going to implement a set
of policies they do as your question
suggests they turn to the same group of
people
that have been
both made sophisticated about issues in
these policy discussion groups and have
been made legitimate in these policy
discussion groups as having more than
just the perspective of their particular
corporation but also that they are
states persons that is that they are
people that look at the broader picture
so the continuity
of these people is very great i also
want to add to that frank now that you
got me kind of rolling on it is that
this also involves experts in america
not just
multi-millionaires and corporate
executives but
very important experts are part of this
uh
power elite that we're talking about as
well
and what i'm then saying is that that
councils on foreign relations committees
for economic development and so on
actually have basically a monopoly
of the respectable expertise in the
united states the people that are sound
and sensible these are all in quotes
respectable henry kissinger being wanted
that's exactly where i'm headed is to
henry kissinger if we look at the career
of henry kissinger we might say well
only in america
in one way yes because here is a person
who's
escapee from from nazi germany who by
going to school here by doing well at
harvard we can say look at him he's been
very important and he has but here is
the other part of kissinger's career
that's so important
while he was at harvard
he was
seen by a man named george bundy who was
the dean of the faculty the head of the
faculty and from a prominent boston
family his father is a corporation
lawyer
in other words he's a well to do person
that happened to be in the academic
world and he called his friends at the
council on foreign relations and he said
you know this guy kissinger is a bright
young guy and he could really be useful
in some of the discussion groups and so
kissinger was invited to be in these
discussion groups and nelson rockefeller
was really taken with kissinger and he
basically then hired him to write things
for him and to write things for
panels of experts that the rockefellers
set up
well in the late 60s
the interesting thing is that of course
that
richard nixon
appointed kissinger as his foreign
policy advisor now the first reason
that's interesting is that supposedly
nixon and kiss and rockefeller excuse me
that nixon and rockefeller were so
different they had all their political
conflicts and yet
nixon was perfectly willing to hire what
seemed to be quotes nelson rockefeller's
man but beyond that the interesting
thing is that
two years after the election at a point
when uh kissinger's star was was quite
high
uh hubert humphrey was interviewed was
taught they were talking about what he
would have done if he was uh
president and he said well it's funny he
said one of the things i was going to do
was appoint henry kissinger he had
talked to henry kissinger before the
election saying if i'm elected will you
be my foreign policy advisor my point is
of course whether we get nixon or
whether we get humphrey there was one
thing we were sure we were going to get
and that was kissinger he was the
rockefeller man yeah but basically by
that time of course he's known to many
of these corporate people his expertise
is very useful to them uh he's been
legitimated through being part of these
organizations like the council but then
let's take it down to what i think
also interesting in terms of the
continuity of a power structure let's
take it down to the early 1980s
ronald reagan
ronald reagan in part ran on a platform
that was practically running against
henry kissinger one of the things the
very conservative republicans do not
like
is what they call eastern establishment
and one of their favorite pet peeves
within the eastern establishment is the
council on foreign relations and one
part of that is henry kissinger
well what do we end up with though
within a year or two we have henry
kissinger as head of the president's
commission on central america in other
words ronald reagan also
then hires henry kissinger so when you
just trace the career of that man
you then see the continuity in the power
structure but at the same time we're
back to our earlier point about are we
just talking about individuals no we're
not because we have to understand that
kissinger first was at a very important
institution called harvard which is one
of the main reservoirs of expertise as
well as a place for upward mobility
where
experts are seen by members of the
ruling class whether they're mcgeorge
bundy or whether their trustees the
university then he went to the council
on foreign relations where he was part
of a discussion group of 20 or 30 people
from all over the country people from
the cia people from the state department
people from corporations people from law
firms other academic experts
and in that situation
he they say this person sees the world
the way we do and he has information
that's that's very useful to us
and so it's this institutional setting
that he's moved through
that brings him into
uh the power structure bill could we
move now to the economic foundation okay
that's a power structure well i think
that
a simple phrase they are the owners and
managers of large corporations and banks
i think that the base of power there are
two key bases of power in the united
states one is a large corporation and
the second is the federal government in
washington when i talk for instance
about a council on foreign relations
it's not council on foreign relations is
not a place of power it is a place where
powerful people discuss
when i talk about the bohemian club and
its bohemian grove retreat in northern
california the bohemian grove is not a
place of power you are not powerful
because you were at the bohemian grove
you're at the bohemian grove because you
were powerful and you are powerful
because you're an owner and manager of a
large corporation so that's the root of
of the power
in the united states there is what i
call a corporate community
which means that the large corporations
in america are interconnected through
ownership
through sharing of information through
putting out products together
through having the same directors
through
hiring each other's managers
that it truly is in that sense a
community
and and they are relatively tightly knit
they they not only share
then a common interest in making a lot
of money
but they also believe they have common
enemies which is very important in
making a community too and their common
enemies are environmentalists
labor and of course those dreadful
bureaucrats in washington who in the
american ideology are constantly
harassing
these poor beleaguered entrepreneurs who
are just struggling to to deliver jobs
for us to make the third billion dollars
yeah
so i think then when we say when you see
that they and we do know this from
interviews that they see themselves
constantly under pressure from as i say
labor environmentalists and from
government trying to regulate them that
gives them a feeling of we
against them
but
but more than that they're not just i
don't just have you know one corporation
and somebody else another one we share
that corporation we have share it in
ownership we share it in directorship uh
and so on so i do think that is the base
of power in the united states doug and
that and that is something that people
really don't like to to say
that is they they want to see power in
individuals and not in general motors
and general electric and
exxon and chase manhattan bank but
actually that's where i think
the power is then from there people like
henry kissinger become very important to
articulate the general policies that
those people need to
continue the corporate community does
develop a set of generalists
maybe a person maybe for instance you
start out running a particular
corporation
you're doing a fine job and you're asked
to be on a couple or three other
corporate boards and from being on all
those different corporate boards you
start to see the bigger picture
and now people say frank would you go to
washington and testify and try to
explain what to these government
officials what we need
you become a generalist for the
corporations as a whole and you may
leave your particular job
in any one corporation but you're still
part of the corporate community you're
not some individual floating around out
there
you have an institutional base you have
a reference group in this
corporate community
that's right so many people are from the
back to a corporation or in the reagan
administration secretary of state the
secretary
of
defense was feds right and a couple of
others
and
certainly they haven't lost their
loyalty to the bechtel corporation the
bechtel corporation is doing really well
with the government contracts i want to
ask you this
this seems like a contradiction in a way
in one hand we say that the government
is dominated or controlled
by
the
wealthy powerful people from the
american ruling class but on the other
hand we see
that the business community
grouses a lot about the bureaucrats in
washington now are they
grousing and complaining about their own
people and the way they run the
government or
are
is it like
a couple of books i've seen where
it's the
inside directors the managers of these
corporations who have basically their
one corporation
uppermost in mind complaining about the
way
the their
upper their betters the ruling class in
washington is running the country for
the benefit of themselves and the
country so you see this division at the
absolutely highest level compared to the
highest level of just merely one
corporation
i think that's a really complex and
important question
because it does seem to be anomaly that
businessmen say that they're powerless
and yet they have all of this money
they're the ones appointed to government
and so on so why is it that businessmen
say they are powerless i've thought
about that a lot and
read a lot about it and i've interviewed
people
and i think that it has several levels
to it as an answer first of all we have
to come
we have to start with the fact that all
americans tend to have the view that
government is awful and rapacious it's
like that's what we always complain
about uh that's that's just sort of the
way we talk
for instance in the reagan
administration they're constantly
talking against big government
constantly complaining about government
and yet
they're constantly getting all of these
subsidies and
being you know using the government in
ways that's useful to them so
in one way in one part of it the answer
is that it's it's just part of our
rhetoric in america
but at the next level
and this uh analysis comes from a
political scientist who does not think
there's a cohesive power lead a man
named grant mcconnell he makes the point
that by constantly criticizing these
government officials it keeps them on
the defensive
you see so it's a very good strategy if
i walk in and i say
doug you're against me aren't you they
said no bill i'm not against you doug
you're always against me you always seem
to be not doing the stuff that really
helps our corporation
this constant complaining about
government keeps
the government people kind of on the
defensive and proving that they're all
right one of the best things that
kennedy ever did from the point of view
of the business community
was during his argument with you the
steel companies over over the
over price rise that they did
he made a comment to somebody my father
always told me businessmen were sons of
[ __ ]
well they constantly then use that on
kennedy and he constantly had to prove
that he was okay
right and there's a wonderful book on on
the free enterprisers that points out
that corporations did fantastically well
under kennedy
so it's
i think it's useful
to do that now but there's another level
and that is
you see
in the american government
the people that are the day-to-day
employees do come from the middle levels
of our society
the values of our country are such
that it's no
great
individual fulfillment to become a
government official because we look down
on government so much they're just
politicians and bureaucrats if this were
a european country with an aristocratic
tradition
members of the upper class might say gee
i think i'll go into the civil service
they would say and say i'm thinking
concretely here of england
and france
so that there might be many people in
the government as permanent employees
who were from the same class as the
business people but in america
that wouldn't be something you would do
if you had lots of money you went to
this nice prep school now you've got
this yale degree you say what am i going
to do with my life you're not going to
say oh i'm going to go work for the
government unless it's the state
department there there's some tradition
of some upper class involvement so they
aren't part of the same networks and in
that sense there's always the
possibility
that
these government bureaucrats
might we don't quite know them so we
don't maybe quite
you see them trust them there's that
there's also a residual idealism in the
country at different times in history
during the new deal during kennedy in
the 1960s a lot of people were
influenced to believe that we needed a
stronger government that the government
should serve the people there's a
populist tradition in the united states
and so some government quote-unquote
bureaucrats we might say employees have
assimilated these beliefs that puts them
in conflict with corporate power there's
also an anti-corporate tradition in the
united states it's not that everyone
emulates and celebrates and goes along
with the corporations
the reason i think your books have had
impact in some quarters is because they
have played to this
distrust of excessive corporate power
and so you get this at times operative
in the government where there actually
are conflicts between the state and the
government and there is a relative
autonomy to some of the government
regulatory
agencies mostly they're packed by people
from business sharing the interests of
business but occasionally you'll get a
nicholas johnson in the fcc who really
believes that the media should be ruled
in the common interests and will go
against right the networks so you get
this kind of contradiction i think
you're absolutely right and it's by
looking precisely at cases like the one
you just named or if we looked at the
federal trade commission in the late six
and late 70s when michael perchick took
it over and he started to really use it
to try to enforce various kinds of laws
and regulations on the corporations and
they fought back against the fcc but
doug i think you're absolutely right i
think that is the final level of
understanding
businessmen's concerns and feeling of
powerlessness and that's precisely the
point
that at because americans believe that
government is
potentially bad and domineering and
because of the populist democratic
tradition of america basically it says
our government you see is founded on all
the people governments in the past were
founded on
divinities or
on kings or the parliament founded a
government but ours clearly says power
is in the people and what that means is
that in any american business person
dominating that government there's a
certain way in which it's illegitimate
and
the final point then that we think we
pick up in interviews and and and uh a
couple people have written about this
even for the 1920s which we all assume
was the heyday of business there was
always that fear that i think that you
well put that namely the people might
take over this government
so in that sense it's not it's not
theirs in the legitimacy sense and so
there's always that concern with the
underlying populist kind of thing and it
does manifest itself sometimes then in
the in the election of liberal people
and and and then the appointment of
liberal officials and and you know
when uh
when we were talking earlier about
campaign finance and i was talking about
people that rose to
to to the heights in terms of running
for president running for vice president
it is also the case but we can see it we
can all name some that there are elected
officials in the united states who are
not part of
the power elite and they very often do
oppose
their positions so i have no doubt there
are pro-labor there are
pro-environmental there are very liberal
elected officials at various levels in
our society and that does create then
real conflict so that
my my point would be it's not that there
aren't such people there my point is
they usually lose just as you say with
the in effect if we look at the fcc or
if we look at the ftc if we look at
various kinds of attempts to create for
instance a consumer protection agency
with some teeth what happens is we osha
that we that we eventually lose they
grind us down and they grind us down
because they have this institutional
base behind them they have more staying
power
and furthermore eventually with these
liberal elected officials they
constantly run at these people one of
the things that's so interesting to me
is to watch the way in which a liberal
politician will come to congress and if
he or she starts to really vote in a way
that's constantly annoying to the
business community they will quotes
target that person they will constantly
send a lot of money
to candidates that are running against
this person in the district so keeping
the person on the defensive letting them
know that one false step and they're
going to eliminate them so
you see my view is not of a power
structure that's sort of sitting there
and it's all signed sealed and delivered
and never challenged
in america the power structure is
constantly challenged but it basically
constantly wins except on you know
occasionally it doesn't but
so so there is real conflict in america
and i think your point really brings
that out well and and uh i i think that
it's important not to deny that but it's
important to see who wins
that's the key to this is that we do
have a pluralistic society but we do not
have a pluralistic economic and
political structure i think that's
excellent i think that
we i think we have the paradox over the
last 20 years that a lot of the social
movements that have happened a lot of
the events have made in some way in some
ways it's a very open society at the
individual personal
kind of level and yet i continue to
believe we have the same corporate power
structure and i don't think it's
necessarily a contradiction in terms
that that
my access to certain kind of information
my right to do things as an individual
which is a very important part of
liberalism that that could be increased
in the society and it has been for for
minorities for women for gays for
handicapped
those kinds of liberal individual
freedoms could actually be in some way
increased and we could still be
relatively powerless
we will continue our discussion
with william dahmhoff on our next
program will discuss conflicts within
the ruling class itself
also how it handles the ferment and
struggles of the people below
how much to concede how much to repress
we'll also discuss the control of
elections and politicians by the ruling
class
and finally we'll talk about local power
structures their particular interests
and their relationship to the national
power structure
i thought i'd share with you this
observation by sociologist c wright
mills who was the first to study
power comprehensively in the united
states
freedom is measured by the amount of
control you have
over the things
upon which you are dependent
well thank you for watching alternative
views
we'd like to thank our camera person
eric eubank
our audio man kevin l west our assistant
editor irene heimer
and as we do every week we wish to thank
austin community television ac tv
for the use of their facilities
alternative view one three
we're getting close to concluding our
ninth year and starting our tenth
and producing alternative views
the program you've just seen is our
334th
and the program is viewed all over the
country
we'd like to thank you for watching
good night
but the most important issue is power is
control in other words if i'm going to
make a few million dollars less for a
few years
okay but i want to keep my my situation
i want to keep the general system
running if a group is a dominant group
or a ruling group we would expect them
to have more of what people value in a
society and certainly this
upper social class we've been talking
about has more wealth it has more income
it certainly has access to the best best
education health care and so on so on
all the measures of who benefits
i think there's that shows that they are
a ruling class i also think that if we
look at the history of any politician
any politician in america
that rises to the very top that what we
find is that a certain point in their
career
they become very involved
with
uh the people that we're talking about
here
and and that the upper class becomes
essential to that politician in terms of
the financing of his or her
campaigns the national level we have a
power elite rooted in large corporation
at the local level we have a growth
machine that's rooted in the attempt to
increase the value of land
and what they want is growth
and which intensifies the use of their
land
the american power structure and ruling
class come under intense scrutiny
in the second in our two-part series
with william domhoff on who rules
america right now on alternative views
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Music]
bye
[Music]
bill domhoff is america's foremost
expert on the american power structure
he has written many books about it and
we're fortunate to continue our two-part
series on who rules america right now
if you happen to have missed the first
of this series we'll present to you a
few short clips of some of the most
salient things that domhave had to say
to see these people as a set of
interacting and intermarrying
set of families who have developed a
whole set of
social institutions that preserve
their way of life and what i found
standing behind these individuals i
believe are large corporations large
foundations a series of research
institutes a series of policy discussion
groups that make it so that a david
rockefeller
is not merely an individual but is in
fact
constantly
involved whether it's with a bank or his
foundation or policy discussion group
like the council on foreign relations
and then one begins to see
that there's an ongoing
institutional structure
and so that even then when david
rockefeller retires you see that the
people that now run chase manhattan bank
that now are the directors of the
council on foreign relations continue to
be the people
that run
the country for instance under kennedy
who ran on a a
platform of getting the country moving
again
we've got to get beyond this stodgy
republican establishment and so on and
yet when he was elected the person he
put in charge of treasury was a man
named c douglas dillon from a man worth
several hundreds of millions of dollars
who from a major investment
house in in new york
when we jumped to jimmy carter who was
our populist and
hamilton jordan
assured us that we were going to see new
faces
in fact the person that we got as our
secretary of treasury was a man named w
michael blumenthal who was the head of
bendix corporation a trustee of the
council on foreign relations a trustee
of the committee for economic
development a trustee of princeton
university
and a member of the trilateral
commission and he becomes our secretary
of treasury
now ronald reagan comes in and he's
going to get rid of the mess in
washington from a neo-conservative
perspective but our secretary of
treasury is a man named donald regan or
was and that was his first secretary of
treasury as you know and and donald
regan was from merrill lynch he was a
member of the council on foreign
relations he was a trustee of the
committee for economic development he
was a trustee of the business roundtable
and what i'm saying of course with those
examples is that when we look
at the cabinet level appointments of the
past 40 years
at the least but we could go back
further but if we look at the last 40
years that whether it's a republican or
a democrat whether it's a populist or a
neoconservative whatever particular
ticket they run on or ideology they run
on in order to attract a coalition of
voters
when they turn to the question of
governing when they turn to the question
of how are they going to implement a set
of policies they do as your question
suggests they turn to the same group of
people so there is there are a whole set
of mechanisms that legitimate some
opinions and make other opinions seem
far out or not worth studying
once this policy has been set
that the media will follow up on this
and you will not find any discussion on
anything on the other side
of this preset agenda by these people
you're talking about or if it is
discussed it's highly criticized
but generally it's just ignored
and it all comes down to the point
you've made in your previous book that
it is within
this range of opinion
within the ruling class that we have our
democracy
anything outside is delegitimized right
bill domhoff is a professor of
psychology and sociology at the
university of california at santa cruz
here's some more background information
on
you may know him by the name of g
william domhoff from a lot of his books
the first book which he came out with as
far as i know was c wright mills and the
power elite c wright will mills was the
first one to come up with a
comprehensive look at power in the
united states in 1956
and then
bill's first big book comprehensive book
was who rules america which has been
read by many many people and others such
as the bohemian grove the higher circles
the powers that be
and the most recent one who rules
america now
if you want to find out
just who does real america and it ain't
you and i
well you really want to read that book
when we talk about whether
a group is ruling or not we have to look
at
three or four
indicators of power
one of course is we've talked we've hit
upon when we've talked about wealth
if a group is a dominant group or a
ruling group we would expect them to
have more of what
people value in a society and certainly
this uh upper social class we've been
talking about has more wealth it has
more income
uh it certainly has access to the best
best education health care and so on so
on all the measures of who benefits
i think there's that shows that they are
a ruling class because we would all like
to be a lot richer we'd all like to be a
lot more secure
uh in our economic circumstance but i
also think that we can show that these
people are a ruling class when we look
at the kinds of policies that are
implemented
by the federal government and these
policies range from subsidies for
specific corporations and industries tax
breaks
a little shaving on regulations and so
on on up to more general policies
policies that
i think basically benefit
large corporations as a group and that
means
kinds of foreign policies that maximize
the possibility of investment overseas
policies at the
domestic level that
that maximize the possibility of a
tranquil and happy and docile workforce
numerous kinds of policy i also think
that if we look at the history of any
politician any politician in america
that rises to the very top
that what we find is that a certain
point in their career
they become very involved
with
the people that we're talking about here
and and that the upper class becomes
essential to that politician in terms of
the financing of his or her
campaigns and that means things like
financing their travel
giving them money in advance so they can
schedule all their television time
giving them the kind of money that
allows them to hire experts and
basically then it gives any politician
that gives it gets involved with these
people a leg up in any particular
political race
and these politicians are not going to
have a set of of policy uh stances that
are going to be uh inimical to
to
the ruling group jimmy carter is a
perfect example jimmy carter is a fine
example and we could say that
he's a nice example in terms of the fact
that it was not really until he got to
the state level
that he got involved with the well to do
of atlanta
and
and then some well-to-do people atlanta
thought that he might be potentially a
national level politician and and got
him involved with the trilateral
commission where he met a lot of people
who in turn
national
elites that
gave him a lot of money but if we look
at nixon
nixon's another kind of interesting
example in that
well-to-do republicans in the los
angeles area were looking for a
candidate to challenge a liberal in
congress and they interviewed literally
put out the word that they wanted to
interview candidates and they decided on
nixon and they bankrolled nixon
from that point forward but but let's
take uh hubert humphrey humphrey was a
liberal person who i think in early
parts of his career was not heavily
involved
with the people i'm talking about but
once he
wanted to go beyond the state level
it's real clear in terms of his campaign
finance that that he was involved with a
relative handful of people that in 1968
for instance lent him 20 25 people lent
him a couple million dollars
for his uh campaign
so
as they say you can look at the liberals
or you can look at ronald reagan you can
look at nixon you look at carter and as
they
when they decide they want to go beyond
a local or state-level milieu they get
involved
with with the people we're talking about
they have to otherwise they can't they
don't have the financial they just don't
have the financial backing it's like
thinking of politics as this real high
stakes poker game that uh you have to
have a few million dollars to be to be
in it and you see this is where we get
back to this question about is there a
power structure
americans are used to thinking well if
there's a power structure we wouldn't
even be allowed to be in politics but in
america you're allowed to run for
president you can run for anything you
want
there's just one thing you better have
several million dollars or access to
people that that have several million
dollar so you see we can say on the one
hand well it's very fair anybody can run
but in fact not anybody can when you get
down to the specifics of the matter so
we have a formally
open
and liberal system but in practice the
way things work out is
that the rich get richer
and they are able to continue a set of
policies that uh that maximize their
advantages
it is also the case but we can see it we
can all name some that there are
elected officials in the united states
who are not part of
the power elite and they very often do
oppose
their positions so i have no doubt there
are pro-labor there are
pro-environmental there are very liberal
elected officials at various levels in
our society and that does create then
real conflict so that
my my point would be it's not that there
aren't such people there my point is
they usually lose just as you say with
in effect if we look at the fcc or if we
look at the ftc if we look at various
kinds of attempts to create for instance
a consumer protection agency with some
teeth what happens is we osha that we
that we eventually lose they grind us
down and they grind us down because they
have this institutional
base behind them they have more staying
power
and furthermore eventually with these
liberal elected officials they
constantly run at these people one of
the things that's so interesting to me
is to watch the way in which a liberal
politician will come to congress and if
he or she starts to really vote in a way
that's constantly annoying to the
business community they will quotes
target that person they will constantly
send a lot of money to candidates that
are running against this person in the
district so keeping the person on the
defensive letting them know that one
false step and they're going to
eliminate them so
you see my view is not of a power
structure that's sort of sitting there
and it's all signed sealed and delivered
and never challenged in america the
power structure is constantly challenged
but it basically constantly wins except
on you know
occasionally it doesn't but
so so there is real conflict in america
and i i think your point really brings
that out well and and uh i i think that
it's important not to deny that but it's
important to see who wins that's
that's the key to this is that we do
have a pluralistic society but we do not
have a pluralistic economic and
political structure i think that's
excellent i think that
we i think we have the paradox over the
last 20 years that a lot of the social
movements that have happened a lot of
the events have made in some way in some
ways it's a very open society at the
individual personal
kind of level and yet i continue to
believe we have the same corporate power
structure and i don't think it's
necessarily a contradiction in terms
that that
my access to certain kind of information
my right to do things as an individual
which is a very important part of
liberalism that that could be increased
in the society and it has been for for
minorities for women for gays for
handicapped
those kinds of liberal individual
freedoms could actually be in some way
increased and we could still be
relatively powerless so far you've
talked about a cohesion
within the ruling class but aren't there
significant conflicts
at times the vietnam war for instance
there were two opposing views where
people the establishment took pro and
anti-war positions i think in reagan's
income tax
reform obviously there's no cohesion or
they can't come to agreement how do you
explain conflicts within the ruling
class what are the main divisions if any
okay and what forms do they take once we
have set this general kind of framework
that we've been talking about
in which we in effect know that these
corporate people feel
a lot of commonness from there
we can go on to say that they do argue
about various kinds of things and that i
do think that we see some relatively
long lasting kinds of different
differences of opinions over
specific
kinds of of issues
and you mentioned
the division of opinion that developed
over the vietnam war which i think was
was very real and very important at the
same time
from my point of view the debate
over what to do went on in precisely the
organizations were talking about that is
putting put put more specifically
in the early 60s i think there was
complete consensus in the power elite
that it was necessary to go into
vietnam
as the war went uh more and more badly
real significant difference of opinion
developed in the
late 60s particularly in the face of the
tet offensive
and this manifested itself then in very
vehement arguments at a place like the
council on foreign relations
and experts came there for instance one
person samuel huntington from harvard
and he would say the discussion groups
things like this he said look
things have changed we've got to look at
this differently first of all there's a
sino-soviet split
second there's no big communist party
now in indonesia that's that's been
wiped out and that that makes
less of a threat in southeast asia
in
in general
thirdly there hasn't been the spread of
the cuban revolution
in latin america
and then fourthly we're now facing a
major ghetto uprising in this country
real
unsettling things are happening and the
peace movement and the peace movement is
the next thing
faced with this
and given what's that that what it's
going to cost us to win in vietnam
we should get out of that war gradually
now
what's interesting is that
a set of people that were known around
washington is the wise men
these were people that johnson brought
in once a month
the wise men
switched their views
on the war well who well there were
about a dozen of them ten or two ten of
them at least were in this council on
foreign relations three investment
bankers three corporate lawyers a couple
retired military all had been in and out
of government in and out of corporations
and they said that they heard all the
government officials talk about what was
what the what was needed after tepp and
they went to johnson and they said to
him
don't send more troops to vietnam
according to all accounts he was kind of
stunned by this and one week later he
went on the tv
and he announced he would not run for
president again
and that was kind of a crucial kind of
turning point
a definitely a division of opinion
developed on how to
deal with this situation
and
uh they turn they change their mind
now there are also longer lasting kinds
of divisions of opinion
between people that in terms of the
american political pers
american political spectrum that we
would call
moderate kinds of conservatives they are
either conservative democrats or
moderate republicans
their opinions differ
from those of very conservative people
sometimes called
ultra conservative
the moderate conservatives come i
believe from the biggest and most
international corporations in america by
and large
these corporations are in favor of more
and more free trade
they are willing to see some kinds of
social welfare policies used they
believe that there is some validity to
a keynesian economics
the ultra conservative people tend to
come from
smaller corporations and privately held
corporations that is where the family
owns it the stock is not publicly traded
and they tend to be in very competitive
kinds of national markets
that they sell their products in some
region of america
and aren't trying to get overseas or
don't have the money to get overseas
those people have been
historically very isolationist on
foreign policy
they have been opposed to the slightest
welfare state
developments including social security
and these people tend to believe that
a deficit in spending is the work of the
devil very anti-labor too against any
concessions to labor whereas the more
moderates are willing to bring them in
or at least the conservative labor
some of them yeah i think there i want
to say that i think i was a little wrong
in
some things that i wrote in the 19 in
the early 70s particularly in 1970 i had
i had
had the understanding from my earlier
work that
the people i've just described as
moderates were moderate towards unions
they're moderate towards labor in the
sense of willing to improve welfare
benefits willing to change things that
workers
complain about within the factory but
they do not like unions uh either
no part of this power structure likes
unions
and the reason we've had unions i'm
convinced
is because of the power of workers
in the industries that have unions
one of the things that
i think is very important to understand
about the
reagan administration
is that i believe that the kinds of
people i've characterized as moderate
conservatives
are basically the people running that
administration people like george
schultz like donald regan like casper
weinberger like baldrige at
malcolm baldrige at commerce they are
basically what i call moderate
conservatives the people in the second
and third level positions in the reagan
government are ultra
conservatives
but then you say well look at the labor
policies the labor policies are very
conservative because unions are less
powerful now the moderates
like the idea of stomping on these
unions
but they couldn't do it in the past so
you couldn't stomp on unions in the
nixon administration not because nixon
was was friendly to unions but because
in the face of the unrest in america his
whole appeal was to hard hats these are
the true american he wasn't going to
attack unions when
he was trying to build them as a base
against these awful students who were
for demonstrating but now we have a
different situation that reagan faces we
have a time of peace and quiescence
within our country maybe there are
people grumbling there are certainly
people becoming poor and i think that's
a tragedy but there's nobody disrupting
america
so and furthermore there's no war going
on out there somewhere
and furthermore there is the
internationalization of production that
has led to enormous number of jobs going
overseas which has decimated the steel
union the auto union and some of the
other in that context you can go get the
union
and that's why i think
reagan is doing it not because he's more
conservative
than these previous administrations but
because the situation has changed in
such a way it's now possible to go after
the union would you say also it's
because there is no
big union
uprising or
like their water back in the
early 1900s and the 30s and the labor
struggles are essentially essentially
over as far as the labor hierarchy is
concerned so they've even brought them
into some of these elite organizations
that you've been talking about that's
absolutely right
right it's absolutely true that the
leadership of the afl-cio
is
invited to sit on the board of a
rockefeller foundation
is invited to be in these discussion
groups like trilateral commissioner
council on foreign relations i think
that some of that is is definitely part
of the picture
but
it's like it's more like once there are
unions and we've got to live with them
then we'll talk to these guys but we're
certainly not really accepting them and
if the time comes that we can undercut
them further we sure will and that
shows the flexibility of the ruling
class that if there is ferment from
below
if there is a challenge to the system
they will
retrench and give a bit so they can
maintain their control but just as soon
as the opposition is weak then they'll
push it back and that's my view about
the moderate conservatives that is they
the squeaky wheel gets the grease and
when there was a real disruption in
american society starting with the civil
rights movement then the anti-war
movement ghetto uprising
they were willing and i mean they were
forced to yeah they were forced to then
they were willing
to have a family assistance plan for
instance they were willing to see better
health care national health care these
were actually programs advocated by this
organization called the committee for
economic development but when the unrest
went away
the policy position of the committee for
economic development changed
in this much more
conservative kind of way i think it's an
important kind of flexibility
that means that
the possibility of reform
keeps the system stable
you see what's implied by your comment
which i agree with or i claim is implied
is that for these people i got it from
your book
no but the most important issue is power
is control in other words if i'm going
to make a few million dollars less for a
few years
okay but i want to keep my situation i
want to keep the general system running
you see in the face of unrest there is
another possibility you can put all the
people in jail you can repress them you
can do very negative kinds of things and
there are sometimes people that advocate
those kinds of solutions and there are
laws in the books which would permit
this if the government decides but it
doesn't work very well i mean often it
it evokes more unrest more rebellion it
has that possibility but even in the
middle 1930s and here i'm jumping to a
time of
extreme labor unrest perhaps the most
militant time that there were
that there was only a short kind of
window of opportunity to use the common
parlance of
uh that when sit down strikes were
legitimate in the minds of most
americans within within a year so those
sit down strikes the
public opinion
was opposed to them even in the 1930s i
think that a majority of american people
were still
rural small town workers
a lot the white collar workers they were
not crazy about
the union movement i think that it can
very conservative of solutions
could have been
could have been enacted against the
union movement
if there had been a different
administration if there had been a
republican administration if there had
not been democrat administrations in
michigan and pennsylvania i think we
would have had continued conflict
in in those labor struggles and i say
that in the context the fact that
after uh u.s steel was organized after
general motors was organized
then they in the case of the steel
workers union they went into illinois
indiana and ohio to try to organize
little steel
and they did not succeed there were many
people killed jailed in ohio every labor
organizer that they sent into ohio was
put into jail at one time or another and
it was not until world war ii
under the
when roosevelt said we've got to have
we've got to stop this labor strife to
fight this war that those that those uh
steel companies were organized and one
of them never
seems to follow logically from your
analysis of the power structure that the
only way that progressive political
change and reform can come in the united
states is through political struggle
from below in which the power structure
is forced to make certain concessions
and certain reforms to stop unrest from
growing into outright rebellion or
revolution that they themselves are not
so generous right
or pro-labor that if you don't have a
strong union movement strong social
movements and agitation
actual struggle for change
the power structure is going to rule on
unopposed and do more or less what's in
their
interests
right everyone else no they're going to
continue to go through their routines
from the way we as sociologists talk to
talk about that point
is in terms of the question of
disrupting people's routines
that is basically a society is organized
in a set of institutions and roles in
such a way
that
people can go about their everyday
business what that means in terms of
people
watching this program they can get up in
the morning and they can go to school
they can look forward to graduating they
can say okay i'm able to get a job i'll
be able to have a family
i'll be able to have my vacations my
weekends
living in that ordinary life
is very compelling it draws people
into those routines
for anything to happen
to lead to change there has to be in
some way a disruption
of those routines
and i'm using that very generally
because if we look at what happened that
changed america in the 30s it was a
massive disruption
of of a non-union
america
by this incredible depression
there was
unions were a very small matter in the
1920s but when the economic system would
no longer work and people were thrown
out of their routines they started to
vote democrat they started to vote and
then when they voted they voted democrat
they started to organize unions
but it was that disruption
and sit-ins you know we get very
concrete
one of the key dramatic elements in the
early 1937 right at the start of 1937
was a city in a general motors factory
in flint michigan
which meant the capitalists could not go
through their routines they could not go
in and make get these cars made and the
sit-in movement then flashed across the
country and all kinds of other factories
and and really gave this tremendous
impetus to to the union but now let's
look at the 60s
the 60s led to a lot of changes not
because of labor disruption not because
of economic failure but first of all
because of the fact that there had been
created
a small black middle class in the south
that
wanted to insist that the country live
up to its its liberal
values and how did they do it
they did it at the key point by
disrupting people's routines they sat
down in lunch counters and said we will
not move we shall not be moved and that
sit-in movement once again spread to
buses to to all kinds of
facilities where people sat in and they
disrupted the lives
of these people they could not in
birmingham for instance they boycott the
downtown they marched through the
downtown now no longer can you just go
downtown and shop can you go to your
office you got to worry something's
going to happen
the anti-war movement did the same thing
the anti-war movement disrupted the
routines of
administrators of faculty indeed of of
the likes of secretary of defense
mcnamara he could not go to harvard and
collect his honorary degree because
there were people out in the streets
protesting
jostling his car hissing and booing and
so on that is what
makes things happen now i'm not
advocating by this say for instance
violence i'm describing and i happen to
believe personally that the best kinds
of disruptions are non-violent direct
action but i'm saying but stepping back
from you know my advocacy there again
into the role of describer or analyst
as what i'm saying is that when we do
see change
what we see is in some way people's
routines have been disrupted and what
will cause that is economic dislocation
wars
sometimes will be some kind of an
accident that will disrupt people's
routines a major oil spill a major
radiation
clear accident like we're seeing now
that's how the union may force people
right it forces people out of their
routines and and also in the face of
these accidents what happens that's very
interesting in terms of our normal
everyday beliefs is that an accident
makes it very hard to manage the news
tremendous amount of what comes across
the media
is when
a spokesperson for the state department
or the president or whatever stands up
at this carefully staged press
conference and tells us what's happening
or is going to happen the corporation
releases a a statement saying we're now
going to build this kind of car whatever
in the face of an accident
they can't sort of get their
viewpoint they can't get their line
together and often will unravel for them
and we get a very revealing picture
then of of a power structure in the face
of a break in routine and of course
watergate was a nice example of that and
finally we end up of all things with the
tapes
of richard nixon's conversations in the
white house now that was over an
accident when a man that wasn't supposed
to be arrested was arrested
you lie about it you don't have your
story real straight and that leads to
another thing and it just kept
unraveling
in this wonderful kind of in that case
it was a disruption in their their
levels and it spread in a way that then
gave us this incredible uh information
about how the power structure operated
another uh example the way in which
we've uh disruption is important but
also we learned
much about the power structure involves
daniel ellsberg who was a policy analyst
for the defense department and
had worked for a think tank called the
rand corporation
had often been an advisor to major
policy makers at these discussion groups
ellsberg was from a union family
but had
gone on to go to harvard and become this
big expert
but in the face of the anti-war movement
it rekindled in him he he reported his
feelings of of
his background and he decided that the
war was so wrong that he was going to
reveal
the origins of this war
by
putting the pentagon papers out in the
general public and so in a word
we learned this amazing detail of of the
fact that of how of how the whole war
policy was made of the fact that they
were saying one thing and doing another
in other words they knew the problems
they were going to have winning that war
at the very time they were saying it was
going to be a lead pipe cinch
so but ellsberg just wasn't somebody
that suddenly decided to give these
papers out it was only the disruption in
the society that gradually got to him
in terms of kind of stripping away the
veneer that he had learned that made him
then re-identify
with people of
uh that were struggling in this society
so accident scandals
break routines and major social
disruptions
like a civil rights movement or a ghetto
uprising which involves the massive
movement of black people from
from
south to north that's one of the largest
migrations of the people in history in
such a short time and that unsettles a
social system here are people that were
basically rural people and farm people
all of a sudden in inner cities in
another atmosphere namely in the north
and
that was a disruption of those cities
partly mostly because of course the
white people didn't like it and then
there's all the white flight
any rate that's what then creates the
opportunities for people to to
do battle with this with these power
structures and in that context the
moderate conservatives are willing to
bend
and
in that sense we get reforms in our
system which may be lost later which
very definitely can be lost later and
that's the uh
the kind of the story of what's happened
with the reagan years that is the
disruption is gone
patriotism is back there's no wars in
that context
uh the conservatives then all of a
sudden talk about how well these were
just liberal experiences just
experiments these were just a bunch of
intellectuals trying out ideas in other
words they totally ignore the fact that
that these things were all done in the
face of real real pressure and they are
of course trying to undercut all those
programs let's turn now to the local
level what is the difference between the
power structure on the local and the
national level and the differences
between the possibilities for individual
participation and impact locally and
nationally i think that local power
structures are rooted not in large
corporations that produce a product
which is which is where the national
power structure is rooted but rather
local power structures are
rooted in real estate in land in
development at the local level we have
what we like to call a growth machine
the national level we have a power elite
rooted in large corporation at the local
level we have a growth machine that's
rooted in the attempt to increase the
value of land and what they want is
growth
and which intensifies the use of their
land
now
that means then that we have to look at
a complex of land owners
developers real estate sales people and
so on and mortgage banks savings and
loans tied around ground development
that's what happens at the local level
all apart the key issues to a local
power structure are the water board
the parking and transportation board the
planning board the zoning board that's
the real politics for
uh local power structure the other
issues are for them
uh symbolic some things that concern
other citizens but the local power
structure is concerned with with
growth now the local power structure
does relate to the national power
structure in a very important way and
that is that what a local power
structure tries to do is to attract
national capital that is they try to
prepare the land
their area so it will be attractive to
the new building the new high-rise
building that general motors wants to
put up somewhere so we try to as a local
city they try to say look we have the
cheapest land that you could want we
have a very nice and docile labor force
we have low taxes so all these local
growth machines compete with each other
to try to get the general motors factory
the exxon office building or more
generally the new campus of the
university of texas they try to get the
new
new defense department installation
because if you bring one of those major
capital kinds of structures into your
city it will mean new jobs for people it
will mean then more money
more spending for the local retailers
and you will then your land will be
valuable because now the local retailer
is making more money so you can charge
him more rent on the building that
you've rented it
so i think that's really important to
understand that that
uh the the land based nature of local
power structures
versus this more capital-based nature of
totally capital-based nature of the
national power structure i've just then
suggested that there's a lot of
commonality between them that they that
they have reasons to work together but
you also must understand that there's
tensions between them because if say the
labor force becomes very radical in a
given city
general motors might say okay we're
leaving
we're going overseas or we're going to
tennessee
and that at that point they can leave
behind a broken local growth machine so
the local growth machine often finds
itself angry with national level capital
when it leaves so there's tension
between them
as well
as well as cooperation
now
it's also important to understand that
at the local level
the primary tension
is created between the growth machine as
it attempts to expand
and the rest of the people
who are trying to live their lives in
their neighborhoods
at the national level we have a lot of
conflict
between the owners of corporations and
other people as workers as workers we
want
more wages which of course for the
capitalist point of view is inflationary
we want uh various kinds of benefits
which from their point of view might
make us lazy and not work as hard and so
on so we have a capital labor tension
in national politics that underlies a
lot of the fights over welfare and
inflation and so on but at the local
level the fight is between a growth
machine and the rest of us who as
neighbors as as living in a neighborhood
the growth machine's tendency is to move
out and move into neighborhoods either
to put in office buildings or to put in
apartment buildings that is say you're
living in this nice wonderful
neighborhood you've bought this house
all people have these you know single
family dwelling and in comes the growth
machine because there's more people now
and they can make more money if they put
a big apartment building in the middle
of your little area and you don't like
that
the constant site is between then the
growth machine and neighborhoods
and that really animates city politics
now
this this conflict can be very liberal
or it can be very reactionary
that is that sometimes neighborhoods are
protecting themselves from toxic waste
from tremendous overcrowding and a
liberal person can certainly understand
that and identify with that kind of with
the neighbors in that conflict but other
times
the conflict is such that it's very
reactionary because the neighbors
are trying to keep out minority people
or they are in essence saying uh we
don't want a more dense zoning because
we like having our two acre lot but by
having a two acre lot they're making
uh housing prices more expensive for
everybody in the city so
in other words you can't then find
enough land to build houses for for for
people of more average income
so
what i'm then saying is that you have to
look at this constant conflict between a
growth machine and neighborhoods
but at the same time you don't
necessarily say one side is going to be
or that the neighborhoods are going to
be progressive
now what then happens in local politics
is
that some neighborhood issue will come
up that is in some way the growth
machine will encroach upon a
neighborhood they're going to put a
bigger freeway in they're going to put a
high-rise in they're going to put a
factory that belches smoke into the
neighborhood and one of those they're
going to put a noisy installation in
the neighborhood will be incredibly
galvanized it will
fight
but once the fight is over in their
neighborhood they tend to lapse back
into their ordinary routines and of
course in terms of something i said
earlier you can now see my
generalization about disruption
people go into action when their
routines are disrupted and if i live in
this nice idyllic neighborhood now
there's going to be this smelly smoke
stacked plant or this noisy
office building or a big freeway right
near my house you've disrupted what i
see is my routine existence you see or
you've now overcrowded this school or
for some people you put minority kids in
this school by building this new
neighborhood you've disrupted what i saw
as my way of life and i become an
activist at the neighborhood level but
once my neighborhood is taken care of i
tend to lapse back
into quiet two once again so in a city
at different times we'll see different
neighborhoods
in action meanwhile the
structures and organizations
institutions of the local power
structure remain intact and remain in
basic control right and they are they're
usually of course rooted in the chamber
of commerce
but there's usually some watchdog tax
organization there's also some
real estate association there's also at
the national level incidentally an
organization called the urban land
institute that does the think tanking
for these local
growth machines
these local growth machines
have committees of the chamber of
commerce that parallel
the government committees that is for
instance for the planning commission
there's also a committee of the chamber
of commerce that looks at planning so
they have a whole parallel structure
to go alongside the government and
usually what happens then incidentally
is
that a person is legitimated as a city
leader by being a president of the
chamber by being the head of its
planning committee and then that person
then runs then excuse me that person
then gets appointed to the planning
commission
then after he or she has been on the
planning commission for a while which
then legitimates them as a city servant
they then run for city government
in one city in northern california
uh in a larger study that was done by
political scientists of 10 or 15 bay
area san francisco bay area city they
had the most wonderful process i mean
these people had such a lock on the
whole thing it was outrageous and that
the way it worked was you'd appoint a
person to the planning commission
midway and then of course you had your
people on the city council midway
through the person on the city council's
second term it was a two-term limit in
that city midway through the person's
second term they would resign and the
person from the planning commission
would be appointed by the rest of the
city council to the city council that
person would then two years later run as
an incumbent
for the next term and then of course do
his resignation after he won his second
election two years so so you had a
process then that everybody was running
was always an incumbent by means of of
appointment but you can see the process
from
a local growth machine member you get
involved in the chamber committee you
get appointed to the planning commission
then you run for city council that's
sort of the ideal career for the local
powershell
where you live have a progressive city
council how were people able to counter
this sort of machine or power structure
politics uh they seem to be able to
maintain it right they have been and but
the important thing to understand is
that where there have been successful
challenges to the growth machine there
has been very great environmental
concern
coupled with usually
student politics that is
when the university of california was
brought to santa cruz by the growth
machine as the perfect complement to the
tourism industry santa cruz is on the uh
wonderful beautiful beach
and its main
main thing for the growth machine is
tourism which means it doesn't want any
dirty industry spoiling but the
university was a clean industry
high level you know springing in
students you get that state budget was a
great coup for that local growth machine
to get uc santa cruz okay
and also furthermore the university runs
in the winter and tourism tends to run
into summer it's perfect but
the university was put inside the city
limits
for water hookups and other minor kind
of reasons
but the university is a giant trojan
horse inside the growth machine because
once this 18 year old vote was put in
the growth machine has not won a single
battle in santa cruz they wanted to
expand northward on the coast with a big
freeway and they would have taken in
huge ranch lands that would have become
40 50 000 people it's all going to be
parked they wanted to expand their
amusement area on a beautiful piece of
land it was stopped by the
environmentalists in the city plus the
student vote
so
i think the answer in santa barbara in
santa cruz in davis california with
progressive governments is a
student vote but right over the hill
from where i live is palo alto
california and in that particular city
the growth machine has also been stopped
in good measure but there you have to
understand that the people stop that
that was a suburban town
and the people who live in that town are
well-to-do people and it's their
neighborhood and they're not they fought
off the growth machine in that town by
getting experts to do a study which
showed that the developable land which
was on these these foothills
that that lane that was actually cheaper
for the city to buy that land and put it
in preserve than to pay for all of the
um
infrastructure that would be needed to
develop that land you see the standard
line to the growth machine is that it's
very good to have development because it
will create more jobs and bring in more
taxes when you do a cost benefit
analysis it often is the case but not
necessarily always that it costs more
to bring in this new growth to ordinary
citizens than they really do
get out of it
so in some places the growth machine has
been stopped there's also a wonderful
kind of
if i may use the word a dialectic that
goes on between the growth machine and a
neighborhood because growth machine will
create a new community
and they'll build all these houses and
the people will be very happy
everything's lovely but as you get more
and more people in the city at a certain
point the very city you've created as a
developer rises up and says you are
going to spoil what you originally
promised if you bring more people
and then all of a sudden there's a vote
against the developers
and they are stopped
so that kind of conflict happened
progressive governments now i want to
say one other thing related to this
growth machine business that that's
outside of a city level
it shows how how
how
different the disruptions can be
santa monica california also has a very
progressive government
what happened there was
it was a it was a city of little
single dwellings very nice little city
on the coast had some well to do but it
was a lot of it was middle class
a new freeway was developed in the late
60s i believe it was called the santa
monica freeway and what that freeway did
was make it possible to
for santa monica now to be a bedroom
community for lots more of la
which was a very attractive possibility
because of smog
that meant that the land in la in santa
monica was now tremendously more
valuable
if you put high rises on it so santa
monica was dramatically transformed into
this community of these huge
apartments
now once you have these people in these
apartments then of course you want to
charge a maximum rent and in the context
of the 70s their rents were going up
like crazy and some of these people were
retired people and they were middle
middle level people
what happened was that some aggressive
people moved to that city and they said
the sensible issue to organize this city
around is rent control
and they went out and ran a rent control
initiative now the first time they lost
but then
something called proposition 13 happened
in california that controlled property
taxes
part of winning that part of the growth
machines in california winning that
proposition 13 was to promise their
renters that that they wouldn't raise
their rents because now property taxes
would be lower but in fact rents went up
the following year in santa monica and
the progressive
politicians and
went back at another growth
a rent control initiative and this time
they won overwhelmingly plus their
candidates won for
for city council but the politics of of
santa monica have to be understood
in terms of of a very dramatically
rapidly changing
situation for the growth machine in
which it had
realized fantastic values thanks to this
freeway put up all these apartment
building but once they started to really
raise the rents on these people the
people rebelled through
rent control so rent control became the
device through which the growth the
growth machine was controlled
struggle etc and then we see the power
structure moving in again with the media
blitz and later campaigns putting a lot
of money right and getting some of these
progressives um out somehow it's a
constant sort of struggle right and in
the case of santa monica
where i think the progressive
politicians were very far-sighted very
clever about this and unders had it had
the kind of theory we're talking about
that allowed them to anticipate they
said where are these these growth
machine people going to strike back at
us they said they're going to strike
back on us talk about crime about more
police and so on so the next program
that the progressives developed was one
around a progressive way of dealing with
the question of crime and and uh
prevention of crime and so on and in
essence what they did was to take away
every issue that the
growth machine tried to use to beat them
at a certain point what happened in
santa monica that again shows this
flexibility
is that the developers would come to him
and say okay we want to develop certain
things what do you want and they'd say
well we'll let you build a building here
if you put a park over here if you put
child care over here and if you put some
low income housing over here we'll let
you develop it
the big developers would cost it out and
they'd say okay
the smaller developers would say it's
blackmail it's blackmail they were oh
they were angry but you know what today
i just read this in the last month or
two in
new york time 60 70 percent of of
american cities are now doing that very
kind of quote blackmail with developers
they're saying you're going to develop
okay you're going to pay for the school
you're going to pay for the new roads
you're going to put a park over here
you're going to put some low income
housing over here i wonder if austin's
doing this yet no no we aren't that
progressive maybe we have a lesson to
learn from now that's the way i mean the
developers will accommodate to that
see that here's the dynamic of america
the power because of our history and our
ideology the way the economic system
work
tremendous amount of power is
lodged then in this these private
economic institutions developers landed
interests at the local level
capital big corporations at the national
level the only thing that other people
can do is to gain some measure
of political power that forces these
economic powers to
in some way
accommodate
when you have in santa cruz you see
where where
progressive and liberal people have
political power what they use that for
is to then make trades
with these business people to to bring
amenities to the cities just recently
the two sides cut a deal in which the
the downtown business community and the
tourism industry agreed
to accept with with no fight an
amusement tax but that amusement tax is
going to be used to fund social services
in santa cruz that would probably be
lost if these reagan cutbacks
go through the ones that are currently
being debated
in congress and certainly were
eliminated reagan proposed getting rid
of all these support services so
we're able to be able to get these
social kinds of services and as i say
you can allow them to build certain
kinds of things if they'll do it in an
environmentally sound way and if they'll
also build other kinds of thing and so
you have this irony of where we're
getting sort of public amenities
but not through taxation which which our
ideology in america generally is such
that it's very hard then to to tax
anybody including these people and to go
after taxing and taxing them directly
they can often then use that against you
but if you say we'll let you develop
this if you give us the following
amenities
it works
well bill you've got a lecture coming up
here and a few minutes at the university
of texas we want to thank you for
my pleasure i've enjoyed it greatly it's
been wonderful and it seems to me that
the
basic to a lot of what you were saying
all the way through is that we do have
an american power structure but the
people have to struggle and organize and
demand and put pressure on it because
otherwise it's liable to do a job on
americans are all liberals in a classic
sense whether they think of themselves
as republicans or democrats and we have
to constantly build on that liberal
tradition use that liberal tradition and
use it against uh
uh the the power structure um it's it's
it's it's part of our culture there's a
history of activism at various levels of
our country there's america's basically
if i put it this way in closing america
is a conservative country with a liberal
ideology in which at various times
we get these chances and uh what you
have to do is make hay when those
chances come like in the 30s or or like
in the 60s
and i think it will come around again
and then the trick is to be there
basically demanding as much democracy as
much civil liberty
as you possibly can all of which are
perfectly legitimate things to ask for
in the united states of america
and that's alternative views for this
time
glad you could join us again
we'd like to thank our camera person
eric eubank our audio man kevin l west
and of course austin community
television ac tv